wir sind nun unterwegs und ich laufe
jetzt schon bevor ich minuten einfach
nur durch velofahrer ist schokolade so
unglaublich und es ist die hauptstadt
des staates
ich will helfen will das könnt ihr jetzt
losgeht
[Musik]
immer am letzten friedrich vormonat fort
wie die übertragung des staates die
velofahrerinnen und fordert straße die
so genannte kritiker mäßiges globales
phänomen wurde ich selber wohne sie
trojans zürich und beobachte die stark
wachsende währung zuge der stadt schon
länger von den fans auf der einen seite
herrscht unglaubliche euphorie auf der
andere erforscht mich nimmt wunder was
und wer steckt eigentlich hinter der
bewegung ist das ganze nur party
bodensee und bewegung mit konkreten und
außenwände treffe ich mich mit aktive
teilnehmenden und wird dann selber teil
von der kritische masse
[Musik]
die kündigung bekommen habe schon mal
ist es zuerst das
[Musik]
die zwei woche an die juni findet die
nächste kritiker mehr statt
ich bin ganz syrien unterwegs
normalerweise würde ich die wahl mit dem
traum noch aber ich gehe jetzt mal
selber fahre wie viel platz sich
eigentlich als wähle voran und ob ich
mich sicher fühle wird
ford nach 20 minuten auf stunde reli
fahre ich würde also von das bo moment
kann hacker nicht wisst wo es wieder
dugard oder autos sind so noch an mir
vorbei ist dass irgendwann ruft dort war
es sicher bin
fazit wenn man so langsam fahrt wie nie
da kommt mir immer irgendwie durch
beim aber als haupt ganz bordmittel aufs
velo auf wisse nicht welche risiken in
kauf zu nehmen und dann wird es wirklich
förderlich
nach meiner erfahrung auf der straße
wurde ich mit ihm reden wo tagtäglich
mit dem velo unterwegs ist und sich
damit kritik am es fürs velo ersetzt es
ist aber schwierig sie finden heute
gemäss ist nämlich selbst organisiert
und hat darum gar keine offizielle
ansprechpersonen oberen kolleg kann ich
den kontakt zum bbq ich rief ihn an der
eschstraße honig vor mit dem velo
arminia anzukurbeln
hinter meister also ich bin froh bin ich
drauf haben muss nicht auf die straße
[Applaus]
generell ist mir der familie in den mini
beide schwächste fordert ich gern helau
aber sie traut sich zum velofahren
[Applaus]
erfolgsspur
und der führt da noch einfach was mache
dann mail av update flügel sich zu ihrer
meinung nach im rucksack und vorsieht
ich weiß nicht was da noch das passiert
ja und du musst ja zu vertrages würde
und nach wieder bedrängt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dollar
[Musik]
ein typisches jedoch vor
menschen mit relativ viele menschen
sneakers und essen 81 prozent vor oder
bewegungen sind wo ich langsam versteht
also velo oder vorerst keine
und wenn jetzt der us film ist es ist
alles wieder für mich ist nur wichtig so
zum mega zentrum mini pci oder fürs velo
zu mir gesagt um das soziale
der eilig im straßenraum hat und der am
klima kraft wird und das passiert im
moment überhaupt nicht und sollte also
das auto ich einfach ein effizientes
mittel was geht darüber herrscht die
kritischen stimmen heute tritt musik
jugendliche junge aber auch sony bemüht
wurde aufgebaut die macher eine stadt
die kritische stimmen überhaupt nicht
ich da an letzte kritik vom ohne
topstars wie dich langfristig verkehrs
eingedeckt und ich glaube so ganz viel
ich glaub es is happening hat ein
flüchtiger blick dass man es auch viel
spaß dass ich wie schön dass man endlich
mal in die sich sicher fühlt und das
macht ihr spaß aber ich glaube manche
band managerin kleine sicher von a nach
b und nur der mutige oder die innovative
vor allem in der kritischen masse der
bedingung dass man sich niemals gekauft
stars sondern dass man sich fühle
der benni gott mit einer klaren luft
straße es sind sicherer bemüht während
der pandemie motive luft sprengen will
sollte einfach eine vorderseite wurde
eine möglichkeit ist offiziell aber ich
möchte wissen ob die vermutlich stimmt
vergleiche zahlen um machen mittels
aufnahme berechnete mini erstellt grafik
zeigt deutlich den ausstieg hat sich
schon länger abgezeichnet
mona hat aber sicher nun boost gehen
emely techno hand desto bessere stimmung
und das wiederum hat wahrscheinlich nur
meter eine marina outlook runde sicher
auch viel spaß und party suchen jetzt
sind wir da auf der landiwiese und ich
rufe alle gestoßen über ihre podcast wo
sie beim velo radio macht was über das
kriegsgerät hat dadurch aber google
gefunden und jetzt bin ich gespannt was
sie dazu sagen hat das einheitlichkeit
oli hat mit kollegen zusammen ein velo
soundbox sie nennen den konsum kamine
oder irgendwo fahre aber so lässt ja ich
sehe das so kristallisiert dass mir
immer zuvorderst sind trotzdem dass es
drei organisiert die bewegung ist und
jede kann losfahren blüht wartet immer
bisherigen etwa der erste schritt macht
und mir sind halt irgendwann zog um etwa
und den fahrerlosen dem problem aber
zurückfallen
aber gut wenn mit führer ist auch ein
video problematisch war jetzt mehr vom
konsum verein immer sind sie ja wir
schaffen was jetzt das war nicht
wiederzuerkennen hast du dritter fahrer
hinter dirk a 31 sind nach dieser
empfinde auch du jetzt links oder rechts
abbaugebiet und jetzt musik von mehr als
die zweitgrößte jetzt natürlich schon
auch noch gar nicht bewusst so sowie der
freiheit kommen als event wohl wenn als
macho letzte runde
ok
richard weltkrieg glaube jetzt nur
einfach zum partymachen warschau lied
wenn ihr velo fahren die märkte sind
falsch und velofahrer aber sind die
kritiker will es halt ein event in behla
die wogen sind mega begeistert logisch
wird stehen dass auch sie aber du kommst
in die dame vilja über 40 was ist wohl
die kultparty xiii und yoga schnitte
dann wenn du denkst ich mich fürs velo
ii setzte es ist ja schön wenn sie gute
partys und das ist ja schön wenn lied
durch der spaßfaktor begeistert werden
für die problematik wurde mobilität aber
söhne sie dass es einfach nur apathisch
und da die man halt jetzt momentan
arbeitsstunden hat je woche immer das
jetzt den thematisiert wird
das war das kind während die kritiker
für ludwig und penny ist kritiker
mäßiger mehr als nur party feder
aber es ist eine demonstration
euroleague laut sie hat man einen guten
vergleich dazu erklärt autofahrer wo
sich zwei mal am tag am nordring zum
stau versammelt sind die auf
demonstration
und darum geht's für die teilnehmende
foto critical mass auch kein grund für
den umzug offizielle bewilligung
innensohle critical mass versteht sich
ganz einfach als erhöhtes
verkehrsaufkommen uwe loos
ich bin jetzt am treffer vom kollektiv
sero so viel dass sie manche wovor die
kritiker begeistert sind und
selbstorganisation von der bewegung
unbedingt land polterte gruppe machte
vorschlag man könnte meinen kritiker
meist sound werke weg laut und mal ganz
ohne musik velofahrer idee und
eigentlich gut da ob es für güter vor
der sand waage entspricht nur dem
grundgedanken von der selbstorganisation
und dann wird der ausspruch wieder
verworfen
so wird es wohl auch in zukunft sound
und porto kritik am spd philipp stört
sich daran dass im kontext für die
kritiker meister-party oft als negative
begleiterscheinung dargestellt wird
ich denke das ist völlig normal dass
inzwischen die jugendbewegungen theilig
und ich bin vor sie dass man party macht
und freunde sind stark flogen ist
gesprengt worden sind wie nie geschlagen
wird also wäre irritiert dass man sich
darüber aufregt das lied party machen
für mich jetzt schon das potenzial neuer
ja fast wie braid einfach auf die
heutzutage wo es ist forschen was sie
damit sich tief aus also das wie
irgendwie präsentation vor dem aus mit
jugend manche beschäftigt ist natürlich
kann um mit marisa lastwagen um dem
metier und jetzt bum bum party sondern
mit pedalen quasi so dass das klima
wieder zurückziehe und sie aber mit
großen
bin da spontan in eine feministische
velo demo gelandet und schien sehr
spannend das wäre momentan erzählen
wichtige bestandteile wurde nicht vor so
politischer bewegung damit achter platz
und aufmerksamkeit schaffen auf der
straße
der unterschied zu den kritikern mäßig
ganz kurz kritik am es eigentlich keine
politische organ da führt sondern dass
wir jeder von der alten post stelle und
hat die feministische velo.de muss ganz
klar meine hand und die ganze claudia
kann der hand was das land kommuniziere
es ist ein rechteckiger monat und bietet
das fühlt sich kritik am es wird
stattfinden jetzt 65 für prophylaxe
blase haben videos und bin gespannt wie
dann die dynamik wird sie nutzen die
durch diverse wartet so gesendet vorne
zu wenig bälle kollege mich mir zusammen
sind und noch ein alter arbeitsplatz
muss ein endlich losgeht hallo
[Musik]
die offizielle schutz dass madonna del
ghisallo
[Musik]
und irgendwie so nötig im kopf dass
alles legal und abzüge stone also hilfe
der papiere aber wir sehen das erste
auto ist ja absolut ja wohl absolut muss
ich mir auch immer so lang den löwen
glück dass ein ort ist wo das concerto
buch entsteht werde und dass ich als
schöner die kritiker massenstart der
einfachen vorarbeit und ja und dann in
die vorletzte lust einen punkt sogar den
ganzen tag blog wo ja für mich ist als
symbol start für für die art and
wirklich das ist das velo ich kann ein
rikschafahrer sabine w mit liebe der
ganz artig und ich werde es ängste
die gemäßigte und die ski ort san
francisco entstanden
die schweiz ist ihr velo bewegung zum
ersten mal eben ins blut straße vor
zürich rollt und gezielt bereit sie eine
[Musik]
und was sehr sehr spannend ist es auch
ist dass sie nicht die der umzug
begleitet wird keine demonstration ist
sondern dass sie teilen mit dass das
organisiert ist
an der strategie gefunden dass er nicht
mal ne zwölfter de site and let die
andré lenz pass über zehn tage vor der
waage werde die wichtigste verhaltens
und verkehrsregeln weg gehen zum
beispiel würde ihnen raten sind ja es
geht los mir verlernte platz mit 20 21
juni gestorbene jetzt mit
gesetzentwürfen momente vorsteht
da wird es schnell
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sehen uns besetzungscoup aggressiven
match becker
als zielgruppe oder zucker dialog mich
sehr stark beschädigt
und diese straße die demonstration ist
politik mache mir das jetzt schockiert
dass kritiker messe stockhus antwort
hört kommuniziere mit denen für das tier
wollten zuerst haben wir wieder
südlichen und westlichen kunden gebracht
ok und das liefere
jeder hat kann dir da
[Musik]
und wie viel liter zu sehen oder sind
zwischen 600 all dem maxi thiel ich sehe
das alles beachtet das problem
mitarbeiterzahlen ruft ig farben und
sind jetzt eigentlich ganz okay wenn das
wetter macht das formales party mal 45
der andere bahn hat den folgen wie tief
und dan ist so ja gut scheißegal
los
wirklich
[Musik]
unglaubliche szene dar
die ganzen stars ich blockiert von will
und jada pinkett bei die richtige
stimmung ist friedlich bedeute sie
verstorbenen worden
sie muss gegen die raucher da ist ich
bin keine 20 minuten mit wort oder so
dass wir mit dieser rolle nicht notwenig
extrem große große wellen schlägt
sondern auto schlagen aber dort wird am
limmatplatz ist wahnsinnig auf die
kabine dürfen nur autos oder war
[Musik]
beschrieben werden
habe sich nur schuldig und richter
fragen warum blockieren sich hier dieses
soll oder nicht riechen sie warum
blockieren sich diese droht was ist ein
blutbad
der grund ist das ist ja ein oral
die bilder sind ein teil vom ok
normalerweise macht die autos im stau
und heute machen die velos den stau
wir sind am kocher die kurt stimmer
christ mich so richtig mit ehrlichkeit
nämlich die hupen der autos mittlerweile
schon forsch als teil von umzug war
du bist der
ich bin nicht so also auch ihrer wäre
jetzt neu für mich entdeckt oder
und jetzt hat man einmal report zum
beischlaf davon überhaupt gut aber man
also bis starker partner weniger doch
mal auf der iss die aufbauen
neuerdings aber können wir machen in
welcher sich die pizza kontakte
im vordergrund
so geht der welt
[Musik]
wobei die richtige sperrte zwei mosley
steht weil die richtigen fahrer sind und
gesperrt ist nämlich niemand wird wieder
alles sind sowieso okay und jetzt wird
es spannend jetzt eine vierte gruppe
dort vor telegramm aus lützow
drehscheibe wo es auch mit philosophie
tragen und zu unter philipp maier mit
dem man das erste spiel hat jetzt eine
schippe
er finde es gar nicht lustig
[Musik]
der channel pro mann gibt es hier so ein
tempo vor
die gegenbewegung
allerdings sie die liebe uns nicht mit
verkehrs hat erfahren sie es
mit dem zusätzlichen monat lang
begleitet haben schon mal ein bisschen
nach über ressourcen im vorwärtsgang und
polizei und animierte die entweder
motzen widerfahre
indem sie mit blaulicht wähler blockade
auflösen
am abend kommt es also an die vom zug
wirklich raus am haus im swallow gast
sind wir zur kerwe stundenlangen einfach
nach der haarwuchs
ich habe kein rating dass das ist jetzt
aber sie sollen es zwischen
tiefsinnigkeit mit der lücke zwischen
ufer der themse zog er hat einfach der
druck jetzt blockiert und das muss mit
dem er in zukunft nur das was auch immer
passiert was übersetzt so viel klar wenn
sich x 800 absätze denn ich so mache ich
so was hat nicht funktioniert hätte aber
sie meine es ist einfach unberechenbar
es ist einfach nicht kontrollierbar und
vdt sich immer weiter und so punkt worum
es
moniz den bienen haushalte und das
gehört aber dazu
mit dem muss man sich abfinden ich
möchte jetzt mal ganz kurz darauf aus
sein
wer steckt jetzt eigentlich hinter
direkt mit ms.de stecke dahinter und
freute sich schon habe ich es logisch
wie jeder zahn nehmen die modewelt umzug
zu dem macht wohl im moment ist aber was
ist jetzt tatsächlich ich kann nur für
mich weder für mich ist es ganz klare
party of rede
und trotzdem stecken ernsthaft die alle
kinder zum beispiel vortrag nachmittags
fürs velo auf der straße ist
allgegenwärtig
folglich aber ernsthaft was passieren
wird wenn die bewegung jetzt nur größer
wird wird stadt zürich reagieren und zum
beispiel immer die innenstadt und letzte
fertig vom monat für autofreie lehre und
wir wird wiederum kritikers community
darauf reagiere
weil sie dann sagt hey die letzte kritik
von monat haben wir ja schon autofrei
jetzt können wir den umzug an einem
anderen tag mache will ich glaube es gar
nicht jünger konflikt es geht jungs
zeigen über motorisierte verkehr und
bewilligte velo event in die innenstadt
machen aber was meinst du findest du
kritiker meister wird ist auch
geschrieben es doch der ohne kommentar
und vergiss nicht kanals abonnieren